quels sont les arbres les plus
extraordinaires au monde je vous en
propose trois ya du boulot l'arbre le
plus haut du monde se trouve dans le
nord de la californie
c'est un séquoia il s'appelle hyperion
et mesure 116 mètres de hauteur cet
emplacement est tenu secret pour éviter
que les touristes ne viennent
l'endommager l'arbre le plus vieux du
monde est un titre très disputé le doyen
se trouverait en suède et c'est un
conifère un épicéa pour être précis
grâce à la natation carbone 14 des
chercheurs ont estimé son âge à plus de
9500 retour en californie pour connaître
le plus gros arbres du monde on le
surnomme général sherman s'est lui aussi
un séquoia il mesure 1,80 m de hauteur
et 30 de circonférence c'est tout
simplement l'organisme vivant le plus
volumineux de la planète